tenemos un total de 24 triángulos y
medio psicodélicos tomaremos entonces la
información que tenemos 24 de estos
triángulos y mi pregunta sería hacia
ustedes cuánto sería 24 entre 3
y lo trabajaremos de la siguiente manera
dividiremos estos 24 triángulos en tres
grandes grupos sería un grupo
tenemos este primer grupo
haremos un segundo grupo
con estos
y haremos un tercer grupo los tres
grupos son iguales se dan cuenta tenemos
la misma cantidad de triángulos en cada
uno de estos grupos así es que si
contamos cuántos triángulos tenemos en
cada uno de estos tres grupos tendremos
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 8 triángulos en cada uno
de estos tres grupos sin embargo podemos
contarlo de otra manera si yo considero
que dividir en estos 24 triángulos en
grupos de tres haré lo siguiente
dibujaré de tres en tres uno
lo que van viendo por dónde va esto 7
8 tendré entonces ocho grupos de tres
triángulos cada uno podemos considerar
24 entre tres grandes grupos cada uno
tendrá ocho triángulos en cada uno o
considerar que veinticuatro dividido en
grupos de tres tendremos ocho grupos
iguales ustedes me pueden decir esto se
parece a la multiplicación que hemos
estado trabajando en otros vídeos y si
tiene sentido porque ustedes aquí pueden
ver que tengo ocho grupos
y cada uno de esos grupos tiene
tres triángulos podemos decir entonces
que 8 por 3 es igual a 24
y estarán absolutamente en lo correcto
podemos decir que si tengo ocho grupos
de tres
tengo un total de 24 o que si tengo 24 y
lo divido en grupos de 3 tendré 8 grupos
iguales haré una limpieza de esto y los
invito a que ustedes piensen cuánto será
entre 12
en tren
para sanz el vídeo inténtelo ustedes
aparte y de regreso lo haremos juntos
considerando que ustedes ya pasaron del
vídeo vamos a hacer este ejercicio si
tenemos 24 triángulos y los dividiremos
en 12 grupos iguales
cómo se manejarán estos tendremos un
grupo dos grupos tres grupos cuatro
grupos 5 grupos 6 grupos 7 8 9 10 11 y
12 cuantos triángulos tendremos en cada
uno de estos 12 grupos pues tendremos
dos triángulos en cada uno que de igual
manera si nosotros pensamos en dividir
estos veinticuatro triángulos
en grupos de 12 haremos lo siguiente
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 este será
nuestro primer grupo de 12
estamos claros este será nuestro primer
grupo de 12 triángulos
así es que tendremos un segundo grupo de
doce triángulos recuerda que estos
grupos siempre son del mismo número de
triángulos son iguales
tendremos entonces 24 triángulos entre
grupos de 12 tendremos dos grupos de 12
si lo vemos desde el punto de vista de
multiplicación podemos decir que tengo
dos grupos
con 12
triángulos cada uno y esto será igual a
un total de 24 triángulos en total
vuelvo a hacer una limpieza y ahora les
pido que ustedes detengan el vídeo lo
pause y me puedan decir cuánto será 24
entre 6
con anaranjado /
y cuánto será 24
entre 4
los invito a que ustedes pausa en el
vídeo dibujen en algún cuaderno o en
alguna hoja estos 24 triángulos y hagan
grupos de 6 y grupos de 4
asumiendo que ustedes hicieron sus
triángulos aparte vamos a empezar con
cada uno de estos grupos que hemos
marcado con anaranjado tendremos el 24
dividido en 6 grupos iguales tendremos
entonces 1
seis grupos iguales no ven uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis grupos iguales podemos
decir entonces que 24 de 36 es igual a 4
lo colocaré aquí
o de igual manera podemos pensar
que dividiremos 24 en grupos de seis
esto lo colocaremos entonces como
uno cada uno de nuestros grupos tendrá 6
uno dos tres cuatro cinco o seis uno de
ellos
otro grupo de seis tenemos entonces dos
otro grupo de seis tendremos entonces
tres
y otro grupo de 6
tenemos entonces cuatro grupos
de seis triángulos y así dividimos 24
entre 6 o podemos manejarlo como lo
hicimos con la multiplicación tengo 4
grupos y cuántos triángulos tiene cada
uno de estos grupos cada uno de estos
grupos tiene 6 4 x 6 será igual
24 de igual manera que podemos decir que
24 en 36 será igual a 4 si nosotros nos
vamos con el siguiente ejercicio que
hicimos 24 entre 4 será dividir 24 entre
cuatro grupos idénticos que de hecho ya
lo tenemos aquí tenemos 1 2 3 4 grupos
idénticos y eso nos dice que cada grupo
de ellos tiene 1 2 3 4 5 6
triángulos 24 entre 4 será igual a 6 que
de hecho también si nosotros dividimos
24 entre grupos de cuatro triángulos
cada uno veremos algo así
seis grupos si nosotros tenemos 24 en
grupos de cuatro triángulos cada uno
tendremos un total de seis triángulos o
podemos decir también que seis
grupos de cuatro
serán igual a 24
esto es una equivalencia podemos decir
que 4 por 6 es igual a 24 de manera
equivalente que 6 por 4 es igual a 24 o
de la misma manera podemos saber que 24
entre 6 es igual a 4 o 24 entre 4 es
igual a 6